foreign
[Music]
Ty I know about cooking I've learned
through hard work drive and passion from
the age of 17 I made food my life and
it's fair to say that since then food
has been the making of me but the sort
of cooking I made my name with intricate
dishes made with the world's finest
ingredients is a million miles away from
the food I grew up on
for the first program in the series I'm
updating some of the home-cooked dishes
I absolutely adored when I was a kid
first up for breakfast at Classic from
my childhood stunning baked beans with
fluffy potato cakes next a modern take
of my favorite childhood lunch fantastic
fish fingers and an irresistible chip
butter my mouth is salivating and I've
got competition in the kitchen as mum
helps make dinner that shouldn't manage
Manny be doing the cooking because she's
the best to cook excuse me when I was a
kid this was my dream dinner super
comforting shepherd's pie with peas and
carrots followed by a steamed date
pudding with butterscotch sauce to die
for let's get a shoe on the road come
this is my ultimate childhood food
breakfast lunch and dinner
first a breakfast to really set you up
for the day easy homemade spicy baked
beans with deliciously light potato
cakes
[Music]
foreign
the first big thing that I remember as a
kid was bacon and beans so this is like
a little rendition
except we're using the most amazing
pancetta Ernie come on disappear
go check some mice now panel get nice
and hot I'm gonna turn these beans into
glamorous beans pancetta into the pan
lightly season that it's cured so it
doesn't need that much seasoning
now start frying off that pancetta
it's amazing how an individual Taste of
baked beans they're somewhat Bland so I
always like to make them a little bit
more spicy
so a nice finely chopped chili with
the seeds chili in
now a bit of garlic
crushed
phenomenal
[Music]
get that bacon really nice and crispy
pry off the chili and the garlic
and then onions my top tip for dicing
finely sliced downwards
slice across
then cut down to Simply dice
bacon onion chili garlic
for that flavor all contained in that
little pan
once you sweat down enough
a little bit of sugar in there
the brown sugar will start to caramelize
darken and enrich it as well at the same
time
that looks beautiful
now
a couple of tablespoons cider vinegar
deglaze the pan it's got that really
nice powerful kick to it now spice that
up
with one of my favorite seasonings
Worcester sauce
bring that to the boil
and add your
passata puree tomatoes
turn that down
simmer the sauce to reduce
then add in the classic baked bean
harico beans
you can buy hurricane beans dried or
canned They are packed with protein and
have a lovely soft texture turn down the
heat
and let the beans absorb
all that beautiful spicy tomato sauce
and just let that simmer now
five or six minutes now for my potato
cakes they're a fantastic way to use
leftover boiled potatoes and are so easy
to make
I'm making a simple potato dough by
adding flour and butter to the mash
that gives it that nice sort of cakey
texture and it goes from this leftover
ball potato to this nice light
flowery
potato Heaven take a nice
spoon a potato lightly flour your board
we're going to fry these crisp
on the outside and just nice and fluffy
in the center now
get your pan nice and hot
we'll start off with olive oil into the
pan
now put the butter around the outside
because it starts heating up by the time
it goes into the center
so it was sort of nut brown
gently
turn it over
love that nice light crisp they look
beautiful
now take them out
potato cake in the middle
and a nice beautiful
spoon
of beans growing up with beans on toast
As a treat
still to this day after all those years
has not changed my love or attitude for
beans especially cooked like that
[Music]
myself
my Smoky spicy homemade baked beans with
light and creamy potato cakes comfort
and satisfaction on a plate
[Music]
coming up I'll be showing you more of
the food that made me the man I am
but first here's a closer look at some
of the key ingredients you'll need to
shop for to make my ultimate lunch and
dinner
starting with Pollock
I grew up on Whitefish like cod and
haddock but today I'm using Pollock
whitefish-like Pollock has a wonderful
sweet firm flaky flesh
Pollock's so versatile bake it batter it
cook it up in fish pie or even cut it
into strips for my fish fingers which
I'm cooking for lunch
[Music]
growing up I ate tons of lamb mince meat
it's generally from less expensive but
tasty Cuts Like neck and belly
you can use lamb mints in so many ways
in Middle Eastern koftas or mixed with
mint for a Twist on a traditional Burger
but as a kid I couldn't get enough of
shepherd's pie and I'm making an amazing
version for dinner
[Music]
ate potatoes almost every day as a kid I
love them but remember it pays to use
them properly they come in three types
flowery waxy and all Rounders
for Mash fried or roasting flowery
potatoes like King Edwards are brilliant
for boiling or salads use waxy potatoes
like Charlotte
[Music]
if you want the best of both worlds in
your kitchen go for an all-rounder like
Desiree I'm using them to make
incredible Oven Chips next
when I was growing up food in Britain
was somewhat different to what it is now
no one had heard of organic you could
even buy avocados in the shops where I
lived Paris kitchens might have been
cooking nouvelle Cuisine but it
certainly hadn't made any inroads around
our way most of my lunch when I was
growing up I was very plain pretty
trashy but I still love it now and again
fish fingers with a delicious chip putty
Secret
of a good chip buddy
is in the potato
now these are Desiree
potatoes one of my first ever jobs
was working in a chip shop I used to put
sacks and sacks of potatoes into the
rumbler which was then the potato peeler
all day long today I'm gonna do
something a bit healthier
for my oven chips with a Twist
simply peel
slice and Blanche for three to four
minutes
drain
season and cover well with Paprika
spread evenly over an oiled baking tray
and place into a preheated oven for 20
minutes
as simple as that next up easy fish
fingers
this is Pollock
a really nice firm delicious fish cut
the fish in finger size battens of fish
put them onto your plate and just
lightly salt them you can do that
literally 20 minutes 30 minutes before
you start cooking the fish
firms the fish up beautifully and it
allows it to become a little bit more
durable especially in the pan now for
the coating start by thoroughly coating
the fish in seasoned flour and then just
roll it it's to get rid of those little
sharp corners
because then it stops those Corners
almost burning in a pan
in to your egg wash
and really coat them
wonderful
and then this is Dill goes brilliantly
well with the fish
and run the deal through my breadcrumbs
that makes it more aromatic
lay them
onto your breadcrumbs
nothing wrong with the chip latte
nothing wrong with fish fingers
let's give it a lovely modern twist
beautiful once the fish fingers are
thoroughly coated they're ready to pan
fry and they'll need around three
minutes on each side
I want the fish fingers to be nice and
crispy get a really nice color on them
first and then we'll flip them over
and finish them with butter
bring the heat up into the pan
a nice
little knob of butter
that'll work wonders with the
breadcrumbs and the deal
nice and carefully
take them out
and look and smell incredible stay nice
and crispy
now to assemble my chip buddy starting
with button thick crusty bread
[Music]
slice of bread
mop up that amazing flavor
on
slice in half never slice in an angle
my mouth is salivating beautiful
on with a chip buddy there's one thing
missing
and it signifies that I've never
forgotten the joy I've come for food but
my God that makes me feel like a
nine-year-old
excuse me for a moment
I want to stuff my face
[Applause]
[Music]
homemade fish fingers are my ultimate
chip buddy so simple to make but trust
me it tastes amazing
when I was a kid there wasn't a lot of
spare money in our house to spend on
fancy ingredients but mum was brilliant
and what she did let me tell you so we
had really tasty hearty food great cakes
amazing puddings all made with the
freshest ingredients that's right isn't
it yes
sure on the road we're cooking the kind
of food mum always dished up starting
with a family favorite steamed date
pudding with a glorious butterscotch
sauce
they weren't called desserts on those
days were they no it was puddings
puddings now I'm gonna sieve a flour
would you out up here Shawna chop those
dates please there was a favorite wasn't
it amazing sew it in
okay but it's almost like an
old-fashioned dessert themed and
everything was sort of steamed you had
Jam roly-proly
so the zest or the orange makes that
really nice and fragrant sort of helps
get that richness to the soot okay yeah
brown sugar in
such an easy recipe yes looks fantastic
on the table
and then treacle
trickle in wow look at that
there's something quite
magical about a spoonful of treacle we
had them in there please thank you and
crack an egg might be whisk it and mix
that into the milk
if I pour in the egg and the milk would
you give that a little mix up please yep
thank you
nice
slow
don't go too fast
you see I always just think that it was
an old-fashioned dessert steamed pudding
do you ever remember me tumbling around
your knees trying to sort of get in
there yeah so you like to lick the ball
didn't you all the time
now lightly Grease the mold you're
always willing to help
but not with washing up some things
never cheat I think I was allergic to
the soap that was your excuse
kids will enjoy this tonight won't they
delicious paper
that goes on so the secret behind the
parchment paper is to keep that nice and
tight tight yep
here we are
good no oh I pushed my hand
come on
tightly covered with foil and placing a
pan of water and let it Steam for around
two hours with a lid on
are you going to wash up God
just for once wash up Mr Remy oh dear
goodness you let that smash mom you
handed it to me and he dropped it come
on whilst mum forces me to break the
habit of a lifetime dude that's the
thought of you washing up it does that
to you here's how to make an amazing
butterscotch sauce to serve with the
pudding
add butter into a pan
brown sugar
golden syrup
foreign
and vanilla seeds
melt and combine over medium Heat
stir in the cream and simmer until
thickened
that's the taste of my childhood in a
jug right there and it will keep in the
fridge for a week
[Music]
now for the main course my all-time
favorite shepherd's pie what's the
secret
behind a really good
shepherd's pie
I would think the vegetables you use in
Brown in it so we're going to use leeks
and onions and start Browning off the
mince you know no color no flavor I've
never forgotten that you know that yep
so
go to have color gotta have color
otherwise it puts that gray tinge on the
shepherd's pie that looks greasy and
super nasty
we don't want that do we and I know you
don't do cheaper nasty let me clear your
peelings man ah all right thank you very
much there's no Nails in there now is
there no
I remember your
amazing shepherd's pie and that lovely
little restaurant used to work in in
sheep Street in Stratford Haven so you
never got food sent back no mum times
have complained that there was not
enough come on no I'm 10 years you never
ever got a complaint no
how long did you work at that restaurant
for
six shoes six shoes
what are you cooking I'm gonna make okay
I saw the modern version of Nanny's
shepherd's pie that shouldn't
[Music]
oh no
sorry
in there we've got a delicious steamed
trickling date pudding
[Music]
um how does Scarlets in school their
friends
how does skeletons call their friends
I'm not too sure on the skeleton come on
okay so two cats are in a race one is
called one two three and the other is
called under twice who won
thanks
[Music]
thank you bye so give that a little fry
off okay
nice
talk to these jokes they get worse gosh
soon having a bit of fun what's the
sauce that's gonna give that a really
nice spicy seasoning
thank you oh that's hot you okay yeah
it's about a PRN
you could put another tomatoes in this
if you like you could yeah
put that mince back in there once it's
drained
I'm just gonna put a little touch I know
you'll go crazy at this a little touch
of red wine
well because I'm going to make it nice
and Rich
okay produce the red wine down yeah and
then start covering your mince
with your stock
not gonna bring it up to the ball okay
and then get some fresh Rosemary okay
like a little taste yes please is it hot
it's a little bit hot be careful
well I don't know either way
as it Cooks the house the wine and the
alcohol disappear it'll be delicious
trust me now God spring onions will chop
up and that's going to go through the
mashed potatoes that's going to sit on
top of that night nicer I like that
savory yeah delicious mince it's laced
with all that red wine nice so Springers
into there Please Mum and I'm gonna
drain off the potatoes hello hello
yeah so we're gonna dry out those
potatoes and then mash them no oh can I
mash them would you
um Holly slice a little knob of butter
in there for Jack please
so what was the restaurant you worked in
there were you a chef
cook
I love the diplomacy well you're a chef
I was a cook
exactly that
potatoes
These are nice and fluffy aren't they
aren't they and do you want them look
delicious mashed potatoes yeah with no
lumps in there
okay what you're getting it hey
it's great having you back in the
kitchen Mommy now yeah seriously brings
back good memories
no
why'd you do that Dad I just wanted to
Fork it to get it nice and spiky so I
want that nice crispy topping
and then lightly grate that cheddar
cheese on top and that goes in the oven
literally 20 minutes 180 minutes Jack
can you open the door please man that
looks lovely doesn't it even though you
said you didn't like it earlier okay
back in the day Mama's meals all came
with two veg and this is no different
but with a modern twist braised peas and
carrots with a fantastic homemade mint
butter
shepherd's pie
glazed on top that looks lovely doesn't
it doesn't it and then the carrots
it's a good carrots that's why I didn't
put carrots in let's put them on the
side I see last job before serving pour
that gorgeous butterscotch sauce over
the pudding
I'm gonna take one at a time that smells
incredible
this is my ultimate childhood dinner
shepherd's pie with crispy cheese champ
topping sweet buttery peas and carrots
and a steamed day pudding dripping in
butterscotch sauce all that's missing
other family Megan Jack Tilly Holly
hello now take a seat
guys so now this is your recipe
Nan's recipe but modernized mum how is
that okay very nice but you can't taste
the wine no that's right so give it a
chance to cook out of Nanny wow that's
amazing do you like it chills yeah man
you did a good job excuse me none of
these recipes revamped
at all
cheers
[Music]
you still don't do the washing up there
are loads more great home cooking
recipes on my app cook with me you can
find it in the App Store good luck
great home cooking is built around
classic dishes everyone's got their
favorites from super simple breakfast to
traditional Sunday roast the secret is
not to let your Classics go stale make
sure you keep your cooking exciting by
tweaking and adapting it here are some
of my ultimate Classics dishes we
couldn't do without in our house but
given delicious new twists first I turn
the quintessentially British breakfast
of bald egg and Soldiers on its head
next my eclectic wholesome take on a
classic plowman's lunch
ham or cheese or Stilton is hard to
dictate which one's the best I'm gonna
put all three in my eldest Megan helps
me rust up a new spin on a classic roast
beef with Yorkshire PUD be amazing it's
incredible there nice big chunks lovely
and we get stuck in to make an
unconventional eaten mess
oh okay I got meringue in my eyes these
are my classic dishes with a Twist
breakfast lunch and dinner first family
favorite boiled eggs with a soldier that
will make your taste buds stand to
attention there's something quite
nostalgic about a boiled egg it's
something that's never lost it's
magically slice that top off and dunk
that Soldier into the yolk
you can't mess with a deliciously runny
yolk but this is what I like to dunk in
it an anchovy Soldier anchovies
interperson water no salt naturally yeah
in terms of very salty so just a touch
of pepper
rich in Omega-3s the amazing tinned
anchovy is a natural flavor enhancer and
I use it to Pepper many a Savory dish
from roast lamb to the humble toasted
Soldier
grind them
it's a really nice smooth paste the
smell of that is almost like being on
the seaside now get your salt butter
and just put half the butter in first 50
50 is the way 50 anchovy 50 butter that
way you've got that real nice salty
creaminess mix that up
it's absolutely delicious trust me
finishing that anchovy butter on a slice
of grilled fish I'm in heaven the bread
this is a Sourdough
delicious very crusty take four nice
slices
now get that pan nice and hot
a couple of tablespoons of that anchovy
oil into the pan and then get your bread
and lightly fry each side
the smell of the anchovy oil is
incredible
take that out
now bring your water up to the boil the
secret of softly boiling an egg is to
place them into the water gently on a
spoon in and just tilt so they don't hit
the bottom nice and light up to the ball
count to five turn the gas down is it
four and a half minutes is it five
minutes for soft boiled egg I've cooked
thousands of them and every time
four and a half minutes whilst that's
boiling get your bread
spread that on there that is incredible
chopped parsley brings that kind of
freshness
goes brilliantly well with the anchovies
hear that crunch
on
inside but I can't resist
oh my God
right gas off one
Beauty in
two
I feel like a five-year-old again
this is that moment when you open the
vault on that little magic inside is all
yours
it's a great Twist on a great classic
wow
[Music]
perfectly soft boiled eggs with dressed
up anchovy butter soldiers
who would have thought that egg and
soldiers could be that delicious
[Music]
thank you
classic recipes tend to be made with
ingredients we all know very well
[Music]
however familiar they are it always pays
to hunt out the very best here are a few
tips when you're buying the key
ingredients for today's lunch and dinner
recipes
[Music]
first off
more classically British than the cheese
that's been produced here since the 12th
century cheddar originally made in the
caves of the cheddar gorge in the west
country it's still Far and Away the UK's
cheese of choice in Britain cheddar
outsells all the other cheeses combined
good quality cheddar has an Amber yellow
Hue and it's firm but not greasy or hard
River beef is the classic granddaddy of
all roasting joints
it's generous marbling of fat keeps its
flavor some meat moist and succulent
as a rule of thumb one rib should
generously feed two mouths to feed my
rabble for dinner tonight I'll be
needing a three rib joint
no roast beef dinner is complete without
the nose tingling the light that is
horseradish sauce a member of the
mustard family this root is related to
Wasabi broccoli and cabbage but looks
more like a knobbly parsnip
for dinner tonight I'm gonna break with
tradition and give my Yorkshire put
batter a delicious horseradish kick
[Music]
and this becomes a classic because it's
delicious and somehow strikes a chord
with us it just works sometimes these
dishes can become tired but a clever
twist helps make them fresh again
can't get more classic than a
centuries-old midday meal of bread
cheese and beer reinvented and marketed
by pubs as a plan one's lunch in the 60s
I'm now giving it my 21st century take
[Music]
with the most amazing but super simple
beer baked bread party and full of
flavor
for a really quick and easy bread dough
sieve a mix of wholemeal and
self-raising white flour with a good
pinch of salt
is really important the rest it's the
first thing I do once I've cracked it
and smelt you want to smell that salt
baked throughout
beer in about 250 ml of beer
[Music]
the reason why this recipe works so well
is it the beer it's got that yeast so
naturally it's going to work beautifully
give that a really good mix I'm looking
for the mixer to be quite wet if the
dough becomes too firm then it's going
to cook dry in the center
just as it starts to fall through the
Whisk that is perfect
beautiful this mix will work really well
as one large loaf but I want to make my
plowmans a little bit more special
small tins give it that kind of intimacy
and I quite like having my own little
loaf
the molds are really nice
lining with butter make sure you butter
the top
now a tablespoon of flour dust inside
the mold
that will stop your mixture sticking
tap out any excess
three quarters fill your little molds
we're going to allow it to sort of Rise
just so it comes above the mold and
forms this really nice miniature loaf
onto the tray centimeter apart into the
oven 25 to 30 minutes at 180.
something quite nice about the smell of
home-baked Breads in the kitchen
delicious
no plan once it's complete without
pickled onions Red Onion is a lot
sweeter less harsh than a white onion
the early days of plan ones you've got
those ghastly sharp pickled onions that
make you almost cry when you're
crunching them on a lightly pickle my
red onion
just push your fingers through so you
get these nice sort of onion rings a
little touch of salt a little sprinkle
of sugar and then a couple of clothes in
there that gives it a really nice sort
of perfume that sort of makes the
pickling slightly more mellow
red wine vinegar now if you haven't got
red wine vinegar white wine vinegar it's
just as good but red matches the Red
Onion so it goes hand in glove a couple
tablespoons of vinegar
just give that a really good mix
particular process use a weight to put
pressure on the onions
as the weight presses down on the onions
the clove the salt the sugar the vinegar
work they're magic and it comes up with
a really nice light fragrant pickle
for my 21st century plants I'm creating
an all-in-one salad and bringing the
traditional elements together with a
Punchy dressing
a tablespoon of English mustard a
tablespoon of honey
a touch of salt and pepper
and finish off with white wine vinegar
and olive oil
[Music]
now generally this sort of three parts
oil to one part vinegar that's the sort
of General base
you don't really think of a vinaigrette
with a plan ones but this is a really
nice sort of modern approach to plowmans
for my Plum and salad I'm using a
mixture of robust and crunchy romaine
lettuce
and Punchy Watercress if I was making a
Watercress soup I'd use the stalks but
the stalks a little bit better so I just
grab them like that pinch them and then
twist
[Music]
um
very peppery very hot but so juicy
Watercress in
your celery chopping nice and finely
it's the one thing that every leaves is
that stick of celery so scatter it
amongst the salad
a bit of oomph and color from some
sliced radishes and sweetness from a
thinly sliced Apple
whilst you're busy throwing your Plum
and salad together do not forget about
your beer bread
before it comes out I'm gonna glaze the
top a little touch of milk that'll put a
really nice finish to the bread back in
for the last five minutes
now for the magic and the plowmans
generally you'd see it as a ham or
cheddar or Stilton almonds it's hard to
dictate which one's the best
so for the ultimate plowmans I'm adding
all three
for your cheddar
peel some nice shards of that delicious
creamy cheddar let's get them dancing on
top
your dressing drizzle round in circles
and then finally
are delicious lightly pickled onions
give them a good squeeze
and not just dot the onions around
bread
is ready
it's got that nice yeasty smell warm
crusty and delicious
[Music]
and there you go that is my classic
modern version of a traditional stunning
plowmans
wow
my delicious all-in-one plan one salad
with individual beer bread loaves
updated for the 21st century
[Music]
I think a fantastic Sunday roast is the
Cornerstone of home cooking it's what
the rest of the week's meals are built
around and I absolutely love it but that
doesn't mean it can't be improved
to make the most out of my roast my main
course is the delicious stuffed roast
rib of beef
complete with Tangy horseradish
Yorkshire puddings
but first i'm enlisting the help of my
eldest fifteen-year-old Megan to
reinvent one of my all-time favorite
classic desserts eaten mess bomb
rice is a mess what's the one thing you
love about he's a mess I love the
meringues now this is a eaten Mess With
a Twist what's the twist in it compared
to the normal one we're gonna freeze it
so it's almost like a sort of eaten mess
bomb wow now I'd like you to whisk the
cream please
half the strawberries are going to go
through the mix and half the
strawberries are going to be turned into
a strawberries in first a little
dusting of icing sugar into the pan and
now the icing sugar will withdraw the
sweetness from the strawberries and
start caramelizing so let me show you a
nice quick way of whisking secret
whisking it's like 10 seconds on
10 seconds off that way your arms don't
get tired now I'm going to take the
cream to a three-quarter stage what is a
three-quarter mix so we leave some sort
of texture in the cream and that's what
we call three-quarter width and you've
got a nice soft Peak
they're caramelized you put a little
touch of water in there that'll help
break down the sugar
and turn that into a really nice
strawberry liquid
now to get it really nice and fine I'm
going to blend it on
Blitz
off okay that's fine I want you to use
the back of the spoon and push that
through the sieve okay now that way if
you don't get those seeds it smells so
good I love the smell nice this is the
exciting part wow oh
magazine right now the meringue your
fingers just crush and Flake the
meringue into the cream how big should I
crush it there at all
there nice big chunks okay lovely
to make this dessert even easier I often
cheat by using good quality Shop Port
meringues and it'll taste that's just
cream and Ray
um hmm
wow it's a little tasty okay
strawberries in next a couple spoons of
the cooling
now look at that now
prepare the mold to transform the
traditional eaten mess into a frozen
bomb form a triple layer of climb film
adding water to the Bowl will help the
Klim film stick as I pour that in I want
you to spread it down okay at the bottom
push it down can you hear that crunch
all right
now
fold the trim film over
put that in the freezer please Megan
please in the freezer she goes
dessert done now for our main course
with a Twist that is the rib eye we've
had that in the fridge not wrapped so
it's sort of almost air dries and it
intensifies the flavor gross so much
quicker and there's less water in the
beef
for me the only downside to perfect
roast dinner is the fight about who
washes up afterwards
so Meg and I are going to avoid that by
cooking everything in one roasting tin
starting with a spinach and mushroom
stuffing
[Music]
still with a salt and pepper please here
we go
some of your left shoulder left shoulder
thank you and with the garlic and the
mushrooms to toss the pan you push down
and pull back down and push back off you
go take your time
push it down don't play very good that's
it push down
nice yeah that was lovely and again
nice oh I'm gonna drop let's see well
done well done more than right we're
going to sort of make a little well a
little touch a butter in the middle
now I'm going to start putting the
spinach in the middle please
so you can push that down spinach is
cold so you're not going to burn
yourself
be confident in the pan toss it and
you'll see it wilting and disintegrating
away wow who would have thought all that
spinach could fit in this pan because
it's a very delicate Leaf it sort of
cooks so quickly put this all on your
board now
and then I just want you to go and give
that
a nice chop then when you're confident
with one hand
we need to pick up the other knife the
other hand
chop it nicely cheers
now outside and come in gently
good
regroup
and take your time
cheers
right
I love that smell what is that lemon
time lemon time is right so you get your
little thyme stalks and you cool down
you sort of strip lemon thyme in now
tarragon little taste
brilliant with beef fantastic with
chicken and fish roughly chop the Target
and I sprinkle and fresh bread crumbs so
the breadcrumbs almost sort of bring the
stuffing together
next we're gonna get an egg yolk now
with the beef this is the exciting part
slice with the bone and then come inside
and go two thirds of the way down
salt
and pepper and then look we pack our
stuffing in there
this amazing it's incredible now just
gently hold that there like that
okay
I'll see you tomorrow what
tying string around the rib will keep it
all together during roasting not too
tight if you tie it too tightly what
happens the sadly will come out that's
right
that's ready for roasting but we're
going to protect it and sit it on a
trivet
so the trivet basically is almost like a
sort of little little bed a little bed
that's right
if you want to enjoy these delicious
roast vegetables at their best make sure
you remove them from the hot oven after
35 minutes and reheat before serving
with your beef
now a little mix for the top a couple of
teaspoons of mustard powder in salt
a couple tablespoons of olive oil mix
that in
a pour my mustard powder over the beef
so this forms a really nice glaze
my one pot roast dinner goes into a hot
oven 15 minutes at 230 degrees then down
to 170 degrees for another two hours yes
very delicious Twist on traditional
Yorkshire puds I'm going to lace mine
with fresh horseradish
start with plain white flour in a bowl
and crack in the eggs adding only half
of your milk at this stage makes it much
easier to whisk all the lumps out and if
like me you like your puddings a little
lighter and crispier add a dribble of
cold water and add salt to season
when you're happy your batter is lump
free whisk in the remaining milk
peel and great horseradish and add a
handful to the mix
it can lead the batter to rest while we
get the meat from the oven that is
beautiful and this is where you really
need to let it rest how long would you
say to rest it for um I like to rest the
meat for at least 20 minutes
just the right amount of time for us to
whack up the oven and to get our
Yorkshire puddings in I love using the
rich dripping but vegetable oil is a
healthier option to get the fluffiest
Yorkshires your tray and fat must be
piping hot for best results take your
jug of batter to the oven and pour the
mixture in there it takes just 15
minutes for our Yorkshire puds to Puff
themselves up and turn a delicious
golden brown with the Yorkshire puddings
on the way and the beef rested we can
finish off the eat and mess bomb run the
bowl under the hot water
twist and pull
nice wow look at that beauty
it's amazing sit down
on
to your plate now the Finishing Touch is
a drizzle of the remaining strawberry
I'm just going to pour this over
an amazing flavor
and some grated mint chocolate and that
is a nice Twist on a classic eaten mess
a delicious eaten mess bomb beautiful
let's go baby
please
it's not around as much
get sorted and the beef is ready to
serve up lift that up place that onto
the board
parsnips
you see why we kept them in halves
they've got all that flavor one
beautiful Big Slice
put that ink
one for Maggie and then on the side good
stuffing the stuffing a bit that's the
best to die for now fantastic nauseous
they're amazing aren't they beautiful
that's for you my darling
on that one there's so many
a beautiful roast beef
with a Twist wow
[Music]
these are my ultimate Classics with a
Twist juicy River beef with horseradish
spiked Yorkshire puds
and scrummy Eaton mess bomb topped with
strawberry couli and mint chocolate
with the younger kids out at friends
it's down to just me tana and Megan to
get stuck in that is a ribeye Fit For A
King oh wow it's cooked beautifully
thank you thank you explain the moments
in the stuffing please the stuffing has
mushrooms lemon thyme tarragon and
spinach favorite apartment or Ginger I
really enjoy doing the stuffing it's not
as hard as it looks bon appetit
there are loads more great home cooking
recipes on my app cook with me you can
find it in the App Store good luck
[Music]